est à monsieur jacques alain bénisti
pour le groupe l'est républicain
oui monsieur le président avant de poser
ma question jouait simplement dire à
monsieur le premier ministre que madame
morano d'engager qu'elle même et que sur
les bancs aujourd'hui des républicains
il y aura que vous n'avez dit très
justement des sanctions qui seront
effectués et mais de grâce ne mettez pas
l'ensemble des députés
sur l'ensemble de ces bancs phase iib
d'abord à une déclaration qui ne cache
qu'il regarde simplement qu'une seule
personne
ma question s'adresse au ministre de la
ville de la jeunesse et des sports
monsieur le ministre
après la mamie honteuse sur les
dotations et la 6e' programmée des
collectivités locales des plus démunis
vendredi dernier vous avez organisé une
opération coup de poing dans le val de
marne avec une dans une petite commune
ormesson accompagné d'une arme et
médiatiques dans le seul but de
démontrer votre fermeté face aux maires
récalcitrants construire des logements
sociaux
heureusement et vous le savez cette
opération oukase a vite tourné au fiasco
et c'est plutôt un flop médiatique que
vous avez été amené à gérer car
premièrement vous annoncez préempté un
terrain communal
alors qu'en fait il s'agissait d'un
terrain de l'état gelé par son
administration depuis plus de 50 ans
totalement isolé des transports et des
commodités deuxièmement vous pensiez
faire monter à l'échafaud
un maire qui se refusait depuis des
lustres à construire des logements
sociaux alors que vous êtes tombé sur
une nouvelle mère qui vient tout juste
d'être élu et qui a au contraire tout le
mal du monde à trouver une réponse et
services de l'état pour pouvoir le g650
familles qui sont en attente de logement
alors monsieur le ministre
pensez vous vraiment qu'au xxième siècle
la méthode de lynchage médiatique d'un
air sur la place publique et la
meilleure des réponses pour les
contraindre à aller dans votre sens
alors que le val de marne est déjà
largement aux
la d30 pour mes rang de super nes q ne
pensez-vous pas le contrat roll que la
méthode du dialogue
et cela vient aussi la nation ministre
du logement propre de l'égalité des
territoires et de la ruralité
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
je suis étonné monsieur le député de
votre question et du ton de votre
question vous le savez la loi sru a été
un formidable levier un formidable outil
en faveur de la mixité sociale pour
l'accès au logement mais vous le savez
aussi nous nous heurtons à des blocages
à des obstacles de nature politique et
lors du comité interministériel à
l'égalité à la citoyenneté nous avons
avec le premier ministre avec le
ministre de la ville a annoncé un
certain nombre de mesures qui sont
d'ailleurs prévues pour certaines
d'entre elles dans la loi et on ne peut
pas accepter que plus d'un million 700
mille personnes dans notre pays soit en
attente d'un logement social comment
expliquer à ses nombreux demandeurs que
des projets de logements sociaux soient
bloquées retardée pour des raisons
politiques pour des organismes locaux
alors oui nous avons décidé de
travailler avec les élus avec les maires
pour les convaincre les convaincre de
signer avec l'état des contrats de
mixité sociale pour structurer les
langues et les outils pour leur
permettre de rattraper leur retard
et lorsque il n'y a pas cette volonté
bien de les contraindre
en reprenant la main en présentant des
terrains en délivrant les permis de
construire et en préparant un projet de
loi pour mieux répartir la production de
logement social pour attribuer les
logements sociaux de manière plus
transparente le manière plus cohérente
en ayant le souci de la mixité sociale
toujours présent à l'esprit alors
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas forcément le
cas en révisant la politique des loyers
ce projet de loi est en cours de
préparation et nous le travail répond
monsieur le député permettez moi de vous
dire que je suis étonné vous qui venait
de signer un contrat de ville qui permet
qui prévoit dans ce contrat que la
plupart des reconstructions que vous
ferez se feront hors quartiers
prioritaires de la politique de la ville
c'est bien qu'avec nous monsieur le
député vous partager cet objectif de
mixité sociale
alors ne cherchez pas la polémique
cavaillé api pour construire mais la
mini logement la parole